So hi, everyone.
Good to see you virtually.
I hope everyone
is staying safe,
and, we'll see how this goes.
I've never actually
given a talk
on what I think
the frontier is.
So I I'll speak
for about fifteen
minutes, twenty minutes,
hopefully no more than that,
and then open up
to questions.
Let me make sure
I time myself.
And today's talk
is going to be
very high level.
It's not a technical
talk, although,
you know, if you
want resources,
I'm happy to point
you to that.
But today is
really a very high
level talk. Everyone
is welcome to,
hopefully, it's
accessible to everyone.
Alright. So a little
bit about me.
So I am a a professor at USC,
the University of
Southern California.
But I think beyond USC,
what I like to say
is my projects
define me. So I'm
very proud of
all my projects,
everyone who works
on my projects,
everyone I collaborate with,
all my students, all my,
partners in all of
these projects,
they're all multi
partner projects.
And here are just
six of them.
Almost all involve
knowledge graphs,
some a little bit, unusually,
and not in a very
traditional way.
Others are much
more traditional.
So, there's ecommerce where we
work a lot with, with
industry partners.
I'll say a little
bit about that,
but, not too much.
There are, AI for social good
projects that I'm
very involved in.
Human trafficking
is a big one,
but also crisis response.
AI networks and society is one
where knowledge
graphs are less
traditionally used.
It starts intersecting with
network signs, actually,
and that's that's
a very interesting
way to, think about
knowledge graphs.
And then, some of
the others are
more moonshot projects that I
think are really,
sort of, relevant to,
to the frontier.
So the common sense reasoning
is one project
where we're trying
to get AI to actually
have common sense,
which is a very hard problem,
and is very related
to the frontier
that, that we hope knowledge
graphs can conquer
eventually.
So let's get started with just
what is a knowledge graph.
Now, you know, this may seem
redundant because,
you're in a conference that is
named after knowledge graphs,
and I I believe we are now in
the third day of
the conference.
So, you know, you
must have seen
a lot on knowledge graphs.
But I I like to give
two definitions,
you know, just so we are on
the same page.
Now one definition is the more
intuitive one,
which is that
a knowledge graph is,
a set of entities, relations,
and attributes, you know,
that are linked together in in
the way that you see over here
represented as
a graph, You know,
but but the key thing is what
is in the graph.
So it's entities, relations,
and attributes.
Entities like Bob
Dylan and Steve Jobs,
relations like, lives
in, was born in,
and attributes like,
Robert, the man,
you know, the the,
what we would
call the semantic
web community as literals.
So, you know, it
can contain a lot
more than that,
but but these are
usually the the
things that most
knowledge graphs
contain. Now there is a second
definition that is
much more technical,
and it's one that you may not
have heard before.
So I want to make sure
I give it to you,
which is that
a knowledge graph is,
a directed labeled
multiracial graph,
with semantics. So
I'll repeat that.
A knowledge graph
is a directed
you can see their
directions labeled.
There are labels
on pretty much
everything,
multiracial because
there are the edge
labels are usually,
there's more than one.
In fact, there's usually more
than five or ten even.
So in that sense,
it's very different
from a social
network where you
just have one
or two relations,
like friends or,
you know, LinkedIn connection
or whatever it is.
But there's only one or two
relations in most
social networks.
In a knowledge graph,
you have many,
many relations usually.
And it's what semantics.
The labels can't
be arbitrary.
They're not, things that don't
make sense, but
there is something
in the knowledge graph,
and that's the knowledge in
the knowledge graph that makes
it amenable to, some
model of semantics.
And I'll say
a little bit about
what we mean by semantics.
It's a complicated issue,
the the notion of semantics.
So that's the definition.
Two definitions.
One, intuitive, one,
more technical.
I prefer the intuitive one,
but you're free to go
with the technical
one as well. Now
why use KG's?
I I like to to
give a very simple
answer to this question.
I think there are
people who are,
who give very
complicated answers
to this question where we try
to find I I think
they are trying
to answer the question,
what are the applications
of KG's?
I think that is
a different question.
The question I want to address
is why do we have knowledge
graphs to begin with?
And it's in order
to answer that,
we should first see what if we
didn't have knowledge
graphs. Right?
So what else is there?
And there's a broad
spectrum of things,
you know, so I I
I'm only showing
two extremes.
One of the extremes is,
natural language. Right?
So this is something that is
very good for humans.
So human readability is very
high for this
where, you know,
you just read it.
You know, you don't
need, you know,
most people can
read and write.
Right? So you can
just read this
and it may it makes
sense to you.
You don't have to think about
the meaning of every word.
You don't have to
parse the grammar.
It's just happening
very naturally
in your brain, you know,
something we don't appreciate
often enough. But there's no
other animal in
the animal kingdom
that can do it, and we can.
So, you know, there's
human readability.
So this is natural language.
And then on the left
hand side,
you have this kind
of very highly
structured dataset, you know,
with a very formal
schema, you know,
whether that's a relational
database model or
some other schema,
but there's usually
a very formal
schema where everything
is prescribed.
You know? So the usually,
these are tables,
and these things
you see in here,
it's very small.
But this is
a a company, model.
So you have a category,
suppliers,
order details, customers,
and you have things
like product ID,
product name, category ID.
So there's a lot of,
very formal semantics
on the left
hand side, whereas
on the right
hand side, you
have very informal
semantics. It's
not really clear
what the semantics are.
How do we understand why we
understand this
kind of document?
It's it's actually a very
complicated problem,
believe it or not.
Philosophers have
grappled with
it over the centuries.
You know, cognitive scientists
are there's an entire field in
cognitive science
and psychology
that looks at language,
that why do we why are we able
to understand
language and work
with language in
the way that we do?
Now knowledge graphs actually
fall in the middle,
and I think that's what makes
them very attractive.
Because on the one hand,
we don't need the kind of
structure that we
have on the left
hand side. So we can have very
semi structured kind of data,
which is incomplete.
You know, there
are some things
are defined, the other things
are not defined.
But at the same time,
there is something
about the knowledge
graph that is very natural.
Like, when you look at this
knowledge graph,
right, it's kind of,
again, you don't have to think
about it as much as you would
for this table.
So Bob Dylan created a song,
and Bob Dylan was
born in the US.
And, you know,
these are fairly
intuitive facts
that you see in
the knowledge graph.
So I like to think
that the the
ideal knowledge graph tries to
capture the best
of both worlds.
And this also leads us to why
the frontier
problem is there,
what makes a knowledge graph
challenging, and what
are the frontier
problems in trying to achieve
the perfect balance
between these two.
Alright. So have you
seen it before?
I think you have, you know,
probably many times.
But, again, just
to be complete,
you know, I'm
sure everyone has
seen it because you must have
typed something in Google that
brings out something
like this.
Right? And all of these things
that you see over here,
so this thing on
the right hand
side is a knowledge panel.
It comes from
the Google knowledge
graph. The thing on the top
where you see the the actual
things to do in San Jose,
which is a query,
is also coming from
the knowledge graph,
but it's linked to
multimodal data.
Right? So there are images.
There's the map, right,
which is also multimodal.
You have other
things that people
have searched for.
You have things
which have been
derived from Wikipedia.
You have things
that are coming
from third party
providers, right,
the hotel rates and so on.
So that there's a,
there's a lot of complicated
things happening when you type
in the query,
but we should not
lose track of the one thing
which is which
makes all of this
possible, which is that,
Google and the companies that
use knowledge graphs for these
kinds of problems
have recognized
that San Jose is
a is an entity.
It is it it's a thing.
It's not just a set
of characters.
It's not just a string,
which is what it
used to be once
upon a time, but it's
actually a thing.
Google can recognize that San
Jose corresponds
to an entity,
in the real world,
which is in its
knowledge graph.
But it goes much further.
What you can also see is that
the free spaces to
visit is a class
of things. That also it's able
to recognize that this doesn't
correspond to one thing,
but this is the query.
So there's a class of things,
which is the places to visit,
and it's the it's
qualified by San Jose.
It's linked by San Jose.
But, you know, that's really
what the user is asking for.
The user is asking
for a set of things,
and it's qualified by
this other thing,
which is San Jose.
So it's actually
quite sophisticated,
you know, the way
that it arrives
at something like this.
And beyond Google,
there are, you know,
enormous use cases today.
So this this is sort
of the application,
slide, you know,
that who's using the knowledge
gaps and why. Again,
I'm sure you are very familiar
with this, but I I do want to
actually see what
what is going
on right now so that we can
think about the future,
the frontier.
So in a nonprofit,
you have the Wikidata,
which is,
kind of like almost
like an open
source Google
knowledge graph,
although there's
there's not a direct
connection between them.
But if you ever
needed something
that looked like
an open source
Google knowledge graph,
then this is
the closest, I think,
that would come to it.
It's a very big crowdsource
knowledge graph that contains
a lot of different things that
links to Wikipedia,
to other knowledge graphs.
This is an amazing dataset and
it's growing. You know,
Microsoft bought LinkedIn and
both of them were
had knowledge
graphs or knowledge graph like
technology even before
the acquisition.
But certainly, there is,
they are very active in in
knowledge graphs
today, as well,
especially the the LinkedIn
graph is is quite
sophisticated.
It's not like a normal
social network.
Right? It has lots of
things in it now.
Again, skills,
your connections
on LinkedIn, the groups
you belong to.
In general, social media has
become very
sophisticated, and,
all the big social
media companies
have something that looks like
a knowledge graph
under the hood.
Amazon has been very actively
promoting the product
graph, you know,
in many conferences.
I think this is
an amazing thing
for ecommerce. It has really
made other people in ecommerce
sit up and take notice,
which I think is very good.
And the team is extremely well
qualified, very well
known researchers.
They they have done
really amazing work.
Some of the researchers had
worked in Google before.
So, you know, there's a lot of
cross cutting innovation that
has happened over the years.
And even Uber, I mean,
this is a snippet
that I saw in
one of the presentations.
I haven't seen too much on it
except that it exists.
So we'll have to wait and see
to see what happens
and how it uses it.
But I I was very encouraged to
actually see that
even Google and,
you know, companies that you
wouldn't associate
very strongly with,
like, web data or,
you know, a very,
heterogeneous
data such as what
Amazon and LinkedIn
and Wikidata
and Google and all
these company now.
Even they are investing in
knowledge graphs.
And, of course,
there are other health
care companies.
There are other companies.
They are all trying to invest
in knowledge
graphs right now.
So it's a golden
era, I think.
Alright. So now
now I I want to
start getting
into the frontier
now that we have
that background
in place. And what I'm showing
you here is is some of you are
probably recognize it.
You know, some others may not
have seen it, although you've
likely heard of it,
which is the Gartner's,
you know,
curve for emerging
technology.
So so Gartner
publishes this for,
several different things.
There's emerging
technologies.
I believe there's one for
strategic technology,
something like that.
This one is for
emerging technologies.
So to specifically look at,
technologies that
are more cutting
edge than others.
And as, you know,
not very long ago in
twenty eighteen,
we we saw knowledge
graphs enter
into the picture.
I think before then,
I don't recall seeing it.
Maybe it did show up,
but I certainly do not recall
the phrase knowledge graphs
showing up before
twenty eighteen.
But if it did,
then I'm sure it
must have been in this
early phase also.
So according to Gartner,
in twenty eighteen,
knowledge graphs
was, you know,
on the innovation trigger.
It was, I hadn't
even approached
the peak of inflated
expectations yet,
which is in itself
interesting because,
the Google knowledge
graph was,
you know, first, publicized,
in twenty eleven.
So this was seven years after
the Google knowledge graph.
And, you know, it's still kind
of just climbing up towards
the the peak of,
inflated expectations.
You know? So it's it may even
have been a little
bit late, I think,
in coming to the,
coming to this curve.
And maybe one
reason why why it
started happening in twenty
eighteen is because some of
the NLP and some of the deep
learning tools,
needed to mature
a little bit before,
you know, we realized the full
potential of knowledge gaps.
And we needed to
see what Google
was doing, you know,
what Amazon was doing,
what big companies
are doing so
that we can sort of learn from
the giants in a way,
because they are
investing a lot
into these technologies.
So finally, in
twenty eighteen,
we do see knowledge
graphs come up.
Now what happens in
twenty nineteen?
Knowledge graphs climbs
a little bit up.
Right? So that's
good news, I guess.
We also see graph
analytics, which has,
you know, kind
of very suddenly
in a way,
because you don't see graph
analytics anywhere over here.
I mean, in this,
twenty eighteen curve,
you know, we're
not seeing there's
nothing here about
graph analytics.
Right? But then in
twenty nineteen,
you know, we see
graph analytics
and somehow it has
gone all the way.
It has managed to
bypass, you know,
this entire first
portion of the curve,
and it's already
in the peak of
inflated expectations.
But, you know,
I I I think that
the two have to
be thought about
together. I think what was
happening was that because of
Neo four g and some
of the other graph,
databases, you know,
they they sort of
came up and they,
they were they
are closely tied
to knowledge graphs,
but they are they are
also, databases.
Right? So they
it's not just for
knowledge graphs.
You can put any
graph into some
of these, infrastructures.
And I think that
within a year,
graph analytics really did go
through this amazing journey
where it was just able
to come to this,
this path, because of heavy
involvement from, from
industry in this.
But knowledge
graphs is climbing
up slowly and steadily.
So now we come to
twenty twenty.
Right? This is
where we are now.
So what do we see?
And now, again,
something really
interesting has
happened, which is
that, you know,
once more, you know,
now we're seeing
ontologies and graphs.
You know? And so
it's not we're
not seeing, graph analytics.
We're not seeing
knowledge graphs,
but we're seeing
ontologies and graphs.
And it's like, you know,
these two things got combined
and then it slid down
a little bit more,
And then now we're
here. Right?
So it's kind of
confusing, I think,
a little bit. Right?
Which is that, you know,
what's happening here?
You know, how how
can something
go in just three years?
You know, first
year, then there,
then a little bit down,
a little bit up.
You know, we don't know what
will happen this year.
Will it even show up?
Is it now on the plateau of
productivity? You don't know.
So it's kind of
an interesting,
you know, it seems
like the consulting
companies can't really make up
their minds on this is,
how I think about it.
And it really depends on what
they are looking
at, you know,
what applications
they are looking at,
who they're talking to.
You know, it's
really not clear
because you can ask some other
people and they will tell you
that it's on the plateau of
productivity,
that it's already
crossed the hype cycle.
I it might even have crossed
the hype cycle as
early as twenty
seventeen or twenty eighteen,
and that now it's actually on
the plateau of productivity.
So, you know, take
this with a grain
of salt. I mean, basically,
if you see this
again next year,
we will see another curve like
it next year, you know,
not too far from today.
We don't know where it might
show up and might
disappear from
the globe altogether.
So, I think we
have to take this
with a grain of salt,
but the encouraging
thing about
this is that it
does seem to be
progressing. Right?
I mean, that is the one thing
that we see over here,
that it is progressing.
It started from
the innovation trigger,
then, you know,
kind of went up,
fluctuated, and is now sort of
coming down.
And, you know, it's it's,
we are really in
a at a time when,
this is starting to
become very mature.
And we are seeing a lot of,
applications and
a lot of people
involved in this and a lot of
companies offering,
products and,
you know, a lot of companies
developing their own,
knowledge graphs and knowledge
graph technologies
under the hood
behind the scenes.
So it's a it's a,
there's a lot going on.
And the other thing I want to
point out very briefly is that
knowledge graphs
are really not
that new. This is
something that
is not surprising
to anyone who has,
been in AI or NLP
for a while.
In fact, you you go back to
the nineteen ninety
one or even before,
and there were
these conferences,
the the message understanding
conference, which was a DARPA
funded conference.
And these were trying
to construct,
what they call
knowledge bases.
Even as far as
the early nineties,
they were trying to extract
information and
using NLP tools,
developing NLP
tools to extract
information from text.
And at at that time,
we call it knowledge bases.
So if you go back
and read some
of the NLP tables
from last twenty,
thirty years, you'll see that
the term knowledge base is
actually not that uncommon.
And, you know, so it's been
around actually,
especially in in NLP.
Now today, there are multiple
fields that are involved.
So I suspect there are some of
you who are coming
from the semantic
website. The
Symantec web likes
to think sometimes that it has
a monopoly on
knowledge graphs,
which is not at all true.
I, in particular,
like to fight against it even
when I attend
the conferences,
which is that, sure,
they they have
formalized some of the,
aspects of knowledge graphs,
like ontology and so on.
We have made a lot of
progress on that.
We have modules like RDF,
but they don't
have a monopoly.
You know, we have the NLP,
as I was just saying,
which is which had also been
working on knowledge bases and
knowledge base
construction for a while.
Even before that, you know,
the AI community
has been working
on graphs for well
before that.
So it's a village.
You know, it's not there's no
one community.
And and that, I hope,
will be a very key takeaway
because you can't if you if
you're only assuming
the semantic
web definition of a knowledge
graph or only
the NLP definition
of a knowledge graph,
then you're missing
out on a very
big part of the community.
And to truly know
the frontier,
you have to look
at what everyone
is doing because, you know,
that it's we can't
ignore, you know,
just because, we are not from
that community or
this community or,
you know, we can't
ignore the work
that has been
done in the other
communities. So there are lots
of people working
on this concept,
sometimes under
different names.
And so there's been a lot more
progress than we would like to
think because sometimes they
will cover a problem
in NLP that
is much better understood in
the semantic web.
Or sometimes in
the semantic web,
they will try to come up with
things that that are actually
much better
understood than NLP
and data mining
in some other,
communities. So with that,
what is the five
year frontier?
You know, given that so much
work has already happened,
we are we already have systems
for extracting
knowledge graphs,
for, querying
knowledge graphs.
You know, all of
that has been,
you know, applied as
well as research.
So what is the five
year frontier?
I think the the the first,
the most important thing and
something which is immediate,
which is already happening,
but it will take four to five
years for it to
truly materialize
in a very big way,
where it becomes
commonplace. You know?
So once it becomes
commonplace,
you know, that's
when we know that,
yes, you know,
it's, it's here.
It's done. It's
not the frontier
anymore. It's inside
the frontier.
And I think that is to broaden
the scope of
knowledge graphs.
So, here are three that that
especially excite me.
I I I only work
on one of them.
I mean, although I want to get
into another one.
But here are the three that I
think are really ripe
for disruption.
One of them is KGs
for manufacturing.
Here we are thinking
about the three
d printing companies.
We're thinking about Siemens,
the big manufacturing
companies.
They collect a lot of data.
They have invested
a lot in IoT,
Internet of Things.
I think the five g revolution
is also going to
be very big for
them for that reason.
So they have a lot of data.
You know, they are investing
more and more in
machine learning
and robotics.
And so what does it take to
actually build
a knowledge graph
for manufacturing?
Because it's it's
a very different
kind of knowledge
graph. Right?
It's not like
the web knowledge
graph where you extract things
from Wikipedia
pages and you put
them in a search engine.
But this this knowledge graph
will be very different.
It will have time
series data.
It will have, numbers
and units and,
you know, time stamped
entities and,
you know, just a lot
of data which is,
which has very
unusual model of
semantics than than what we
would normally
expect a knowledge
graph to have.
There's KGs in legal domains.
This one is exciting
because, you know,
the legal profession
has become
very complicated.
You know, more and more legal
firms are actually moving to
the model where they're trying
to save money. So
they are willing
to invest in technology that
will allow them to save money
on legal research
and, you know,
finding things that
are relevant.
So I I think we are there are
a number of companies
that already
in here.
They are primarily NLP based,
but I think we will we will
start to see a lot
more knowledge
graphs, especially
for international
law firms for, you know,
some of the law
firms that work
in many different markets.
And then KG is for health and
epidemiology.
This, of course,
is very big right now. Right?
And, in fact, on this
point, you know,
we recently
published an article
where we discussed,
it's kind of almost
like an opinion
piece, but it's
more scientifically
written, which
is that what are
the opportunities
for knowledge
gaps in COVID nineteen.
And, you know,
we it was really
encouraging to find that when
we wrote this in
early twenty twenty,
by the time it got published,
which was very recent,
there are already
three or four
different big
implementations that had,
for COVID nineteen
knowledge graphs.
People had released
a lot of data on,
COVID nineteen.
And, there's a silver lining
behind this pandemic.
It's it's really shown us that
the world is ready to,
adopt new technology,
you know,
including the web
conferencing,
the the, user machine
learning for,
various things.
We have seen progress
in education
and government and
all kinds of things,
And I don't think
we'll go back.
Like, you know,
once this pandemic is over,
some of what we
had before will
come back. That's
what everyone
is saying. You know,
everyone can't stay
isolated forever.
But a lot of
things that we are
doing now is actually going to
is here to stay.
Now the other one for the five
year frontiers, KG
is for social good.
This is something that,
some of us are very
interested in,
but it's it's growing.
It's growing.
On the right hand side,
what you're seeing
over here is
from McKinsey.
You know, this is,
something that
McKinsey put out in,
fairly recently.
And what they tried to do was
to figure out, you know,
all of these
different AI tools.
Can they be applied
to these domains?
And, to, to what
extent can they
be applied? And
so if it's like
a big circle, that
means the application
is quite big. It's higher.
And I want to
point you to just
two things, which
are, you know,
language understanding,
which is,
you know, natural
language processing,
which are very intimately
connected to
knowledge graphs,
but also deep learning on
structured data.
You everyone here
or most people
have probably heard the recent
news that came
out of DeepMind,
right, where they were able to
solve a problem
that many people
said are are decades away from
being solved, you know,
which is a protein
folding problem.
That is an example of deep
learning on structured data.
You know, but we
also have deep
learning on tables.
We have deep learning
on knowledge
graphs. So there's
a this one,
I think this is
very exciting,
and we will see
a lot more to it.
So somehow even
though you don't
see the freeze
knowledge graphs,
the knowledge graphs
are, you know,
they are, they
are very relevant
to two or three
different fields
over here. So I think this is
very exciting, and this is
something where we
are doing a lot
of work. So what's
the tenure frontier?
I think the, you know,
the the single
biggest question
that we are dealing with right
now as a community is that,
what is knowledge?
You know, so this is a problem
that it's best not to get into
a deep discussion about it,
But I think this diagram here
hopefully conveys to you,
why it's a complicated
question,
especially in this era where
everyone has
an opinion and it's
it's very difficult
to separate
the opinion from
the facts. Right?
So we are some
people are saying
we are in a post
truth era. Right?
And, we have social media that
that you know, everyone just
sometimes we have
contradictions.
We have conspiracy theories.
You have sarcasm.
You have beliefs.
You have all kinds of things.
So, even though this
is from philosophy,
I think you will
recognize that
there's everything
from guesses
to nonsense to knowledge,
which is very,
strong knowledge, you know,
kind of like
scientific knowledge.
There's, you know,
all the things that are true,
but people don't want
to believe them.
They are just pure beliefs.
There's knowledge,
which is kind of very fuzzy.
It's very informed.
You can't define it.
You can't describe it.
You know, and then there's
knowledge and
memory, you know,
and so on. So it's
a it's a hard
problem. What do we
mean by knowledge?
What goes into our
knowledge graph?
How do we qualify it?
How do we reason about it?
You know, because so far,
we're kind of
just dealing with
this portion in the middle and
a very narrow subset of that.
And then the other problem is
the semantics. So
if you remember
at the very beginning,
the definition I had given was
that a knowledge graph
is a multiracial
directed labeled graph
with semantics.
But now the question is,
what is semantics?
What's the meaning
of meaning?
Again, it turns
out the semantic
web community has an ontology
or a schema where
they say that
here's the ontology
and the knowledge
graph is defined according to
the ontology, and
they are really
coming at it from the very
structured side
of the equation.
But then the NLP
people are seeing,
well, you know,
the the you know,
these word embeddings,
the deep learning tools,
they have a very different
conception of semantics.
And what they are
saying is that
that word such as
quark is the meaning
of this word can
only be understood
if you know what
the context of
the word is. So here we have
three quarks from
Master Mark.
This is from the novels
Fennegan Smith,
an unreadable novel.
Quark, one of
the most influential
and modern for
all for all those
of you who are from,
who are Star Trek
fans as I am,
this is a character
on Star Trek.
For for those of you
who are physicists,
quark's and have
obviously a meaning
in physics, but quark is also
a French cheese.
You know, I'm sure there are
other meanings as well.
So it's not so clear that we
actually get something out of
a word sitting in isolation or
even a concept sitting
in isolation.
The the context is
very important.
And here, this slide
is from Adobe.
Not the slide, but the figure
is from Adobe. But basically,
the the what they
are, you know,
what what I think
can be understood
from what, everyone
is discussing
about context is that this is
a tenure problem.
To understand context,
to understand semantics,
to understand knowledge,
these are very hard problems.
And if we are able to do it,
if ultimately our AI and our
knowledge graphs
are context aware,
then we will be
able to perceive
at the same level
as a human does.
And the word
perceive here should
be construed very broadly,
where we are able
to see something
or read something.
And it's not just a word or
the the immediate, impact,
but we will be able to see it
in its context.
And we'll be able
to understand
it in its context,
which right now we
are not able to do.
And then just one or two more
slides and I'll stop
for questions.
I know I'm running over time.
But here's my fifteen
year frontier.
And this is I I won't even try
to go beyond that.
And, you know, it's not clear
whether this
fifteen year the,
you know, the longer
you go out,
you know, the more,
uncertain things
become. Right?
So we don't know
if this fifteen
year is actually
a fifteen year
frontier or it's,
it might actually get done in
eight years. We
just don't know.
It's extremely uncertain where
this frontier lies.
But I do believe
that, you know,
the the conversation around
artificial
general intelligence
is very much active.
You know, a lot of people are
off the view that we are kind
of now moving into this,
EGI era because,
you know, the ANI,
the artificial narrow
intelligence,
you know, we're
kind of there.
You know, we have
very good tools now,
you know, the deep
learning tools.
The ANI, you know,
the deep mind tool
like you just saw,
the protein folding,
you know,
you might wanna
look that up or
the Go playing,
you know, AlphaGo,
which can be Grandmaster.
Those are all
examples of narrow
intelligence. The
reason is they
are very good at
that one task.
Right? But you can't actually
turn them onto other tasks,
not without significant
recraining,
redoing. A nice story about
the protein folding one,
if you look deep
into it, is that,
you know, it turns
out that that
the DeepMind team actually had
to work on that
for two years.
So when they first started on
that problem almost
two years ago,
the first system
that they came
out with for
protein folding was
really not that great.
It was good, but it was it
wouldn't have made the news in
the way that this
system just did.
So they they they
in interviews,
they said that they had to go
back to the drawing
board a lot
of times. They had to redesign
the network. Then they
had to clean it.
They had to do a lot
of trial and error,
and they had to do
a lot of cleaning,
which they can do because they
have all those resources.
But basically,
they had to really
approach the problem
from a very
ANI perspective.
But we're now starting to move
into this field where we are
looking more and
more in general
intelligence. What do we need
to do to build an AI that can
do many different things at
the same time, and
what will that take?
And then can we even
reach this point?
So this it's very uncertain
whether we will get here,
or how long it will take.
And then there is this thing
called a singularity event.
This is where I think we start
moving to science fiction,
but we never know,
which is that,
you know, the super
intelligence.
You know, some
people say, well,
you know, this is coming.
This is coming.
But we first need to come here
and then we have
to come here.
Right? So in order
to come from
ANI to AGI,
there are all
these things that
just listed six six
different things,
but there are many
more that all
need to be solved.
You know, so
causal knowledge,
the, you you know,
the common sense,
which is something
we are working on.
It's a four year program.
Context, which I
sort of, you know,
being context
aware is the four
is the five year sorry,
a ten year problem.
But then if you
want to explain
the explain our outputs based
on the context and so on,
that's maybe another
five years.
How can AI adapt to novelty,
something it has
never seen before,
not even from a distributional
standpoint? You know,
how do we reason about
events and time?
Theory of mind,
how do we reason about other
people's beliefs?
This is something we are very
good at doing, but animals are
are not that good at doing.
How do we get
a machine to do that?
So there are lots
of interesting,
questions that have
to be answered.
And, with knowledge
graphs, you know,
these are very closely related
to knowledge graphs
because, you know,
the the if we are
able to solve
some of these issues, then,
we would need to do it for our
knowledge graphs as well.
So, you know, common sense is
kind of knowledge. Right?
We have a lot of facts about
the world in our head,
and that presumably can be
represented as
a knowledge graph.
Similarly, when we have,
something like
causal knowledge,
we can represent
this as a knowledge
graph. But how do we
make the knowledge
graph more causal? Right?
And so that's
it's they're very
tied together. So I think by
the time we get here,
the boundary between
the knowledge
graph and the general AI will
have blurred. They will have
become one and
the same because,
we need them. It's like you
you're not different
from your memory.
Right? You can't
totally separate
a lot of things
that is that are
in your brain. They
kind of go together.
So I think that
is where the true
fifteen year framework lies.
Combining the knowledge graph
with the reasoning,
the the actual intelligence,
it all has to come together in
a single architecture.
So with that,
maybe we have time
for a few questions.
But I'm happy to connect on
LinkedIn with,
anyone who has,
who has other questions,
wants to do a deep
dive into this.
You know, please do reach out
to me on LinkedIn,
and we can also we can have
broader discussions,
Darren as well.
Thank you, Mayank.
Thank you for your talk.
We do have a couple
questions,
and I see, some
more are coming,
on the chat. So, Mayank,
can you can you
read the chat?
Do you do you want to,
pick up the questions
yourself?
Sure. So I think,
one question is,
do McKinsey and
or others publish
similar charts?
So, Larry, by similar,
I'm I'm I'm assuming that you
are you're you mentioned
a high curve,
or did you mean
the other one,
the KG's for social guide?
I think that's
the high curve.
That's when the you
were showing
the high curve that
that question came.
Yeah. I don't
think I I have not
seen such a slide
from McKinsey.
I have seen it
from Accenture,
and from Deloitte.
I think Accenture and Deloitte
definitely come out with,
I haven't seen
a curve from them.
I have seen, them see, okay,
what are the what are the top
technology trends?
I think if I'm
remembering correctly,
either from Accenture
or Deloitte
or both, I know that they come
out with technology
trends, and,
I have some of them
on my machine.
But I don't really see a hype
curve as such that they have
come out with. I
think Dartmouth
has really, know,
if anyone else
tries to come out
with that, they
it would probably
look like they
are imitating and
I'm not sure that that's very
flattering. So,
I haven't seen
a curve like that
from anywhere from
anyone except
to to be honest.
So we we have, we
have, people from,
Deloitte and
Accenture attending
this conference and and other
consulting.